the opening scene features a stranger in
a suit who checks into a remote Hotel
named Renata looking for peace Solitude
and an escape from the outside world
there he is received by the hotel
manager who guides him towards his
designated room The Stranger seems to
have obsessive-compulsive Tendencies as
he starts arranging his room in a
perfect order after a while of resting
he walks out and wanders around the
hotel which appears deserted he explores
various areas such as the swimming pool
and the snooker room before eventually
returning to his room in this entire
time there seems to be something going
on inside the stranger's mind as he
looks curious and confused as the night
falls he switches off the lights in
order to retire to bed body is unable to
sleep as a result he turns on the
television that has merely one channel
Animal Planet once again departing from
his room he makes his way to the hotel's
bar and meets the young bartender who
extends a drink off her however the
stranger takes notice of a rule saying
no drinks after 9 pm so he politely
declines the offer the next morning The
Stranger appears in the dining hall for
breakfast and sits beside an elderly
lady he has a red book in his hand but
instead of focusing on it he looks
around with a curious and perplexed
expression on his face despite the
elderly woman trying to talk to him the
stranger's thoughts seem to drift
elsewhere after breakfast he is walking
towards his room when he notices a woman
named Ginny doing yoga he watches her
for a while and as soon as she spots him
he walks away further along his path he
comes across the hotel manager of fixing
rules and regulation templates to a wall
beside him there is his paralyzed wife
in a wheelchair who keeps on Staring at
the stranger appearing a bit creepy
later that day The Stranger goes for a
swim after a few laps he lays down on a
reclining chair with the same red book
in hand Jenny also enters the pool area
and gracefully dives into the water The
Stranger is captivated by her beauty due
to which she is unable to take his gaze
off of her not long after she comes to
sit next to him and starts chatting in a
active way the closeness turns him on
but before the stranger can say anything
Jenny's boyfriend walks in and takes her
away in the evening The Stranger makes
his way to the Hotel bar where the
bartender offers him some cigarettes The
Stranger this time notices a no smoking
rule but the bartender exclaims that
such regulations only prevent one from
enjoying themselves this time the
stranger decides to break the rule and
lights up a cigarette it's evident that
it's his first time because he starts
coughing as a result of this the
bartender demonstrates to him the right
way to obtain cancer teaching him how to
feel the nicotine inside as the night
falls The Stranger retreats to his bed
only to be plagged by a moaning voice of
the yoga lady from the Next Room the
voice again turns him on and unable to
control his emotions he ends up touching
himself and for this he doesn't even
have to break a rule the following day
as the stranger is heading towards the
breakfast Hall he notices the bartender
peeking in a room that belongs to the
same elderly woman from earlier this
angers The Stranger so he chastises the
bartender prompting him to leave but
after a while he himself off peeks into
the room and notices something shocking
the elderly lady is trying to satisfy
her husband who is beating himself what
following breakfast The Stranger
proceeds to the snucker room where he
meets another lodger who claims himself
to be a businessman as their
conversation unfolds The Stranger asks
whether the businessman has detected
anything out of the ordinary about the
Renata hotel to which the latter answers
in the negative witnessing his confused
demeanor and distress the businessman
offers him a pill assuring him that it
will make him a completely different
person when he wakes up the following
day the businessman is also ready to
provide as many pills as he wants but
this assistance comes with a condition
The Stranger must help him in locating a
misplaced key later on his way back to
his room The Stranger unexpectedly bumps
into the maid as they gather their
belongings from the floor The Stranger
tries to strike a conversation with her
but before that she asks for the reason
why he is at the Renata The Stranger has
no answer so the maid walks away on the
same evening all the guests Gather in
the dining hall where the hotel manager
announces some arrangements for their
entertainment while they enjoy their
dinner in order to perform the First Act
the paralyzed woman is brought onto the
stage along with her son who is none
other than the bartender the bartender
uses his mother's paralyzed body in a
puppet-like manner in order to deliver a
series of awful jokes here we notice the
strange situation that the guests react
only after The Stranger looks at them
appearing as if his gaze triggers their
reaction upon the conclusion of the
First Act the stage welcomes the hotel
manager's daughter the same maid from
earlier she sings a beautiful song which
captivates the entire audience as the
song draws to an end an unexpected surge
of emotion overcomes the maid causing
tears to stream down her cheeks the
evening ends with the dinner and the
stranger consumes the offered pill the
next morning he wakes up and looks more
active than before he freshens up and
carries out his daily morning routine
driven by a desire for more of the
transformative pills the stranger
resolves to assist the businessman to
locate his misplaced key before long he
comes across the paralyzed this lady in
the hallway and notices her neck adorned
with a locket believing that it might be
the same key that he is looking for the
stranger puts his hand inside of her
clothes only to uncover a ring instead
after this he picks her up and checks
her back pocket there he finally finds
the key and retrieves it afterwards The
Stranger heads to the businessman's room
to return the key and secure the
promised pills the latter appears to be
playing a card game with the hotel
manager they ask the stranger to join
them in the game to which he agrees in
the middle of the gameplay the hotel
manager departs on errands leaving the
stranger in the businessman to continue
seizing the opportunity The Stranger
hands over the key and in return he
receives a vial containing a limited
number of pills the businessman then
challenges the stranger to one more card
game promising an additional bottle full
of pills if he wins our weird hero
agrees right away and to everyone's
surprise he ends up Victorious thus
earning both the bottles of pills later
in the day the stranger is swimming in
the pool when he is approached by the
bartender their conversation steers
towards the previous night's performance
during which the Bartender discloses the
truth that the hotel manager forces them
to perform those acts he goes on to say
that the manager controls them
manipulating them through the fear of
the unknown while talking the bartender
gradually draws nearer appearing as if
he is about to kiss the stranger their
moment however is interrupted by the
arrival of the maid who enters with
towels for them in the evening as the
stranger is taking a relaxing shower
there is a sudden knock on his door on
answering Eddie is greeted by the
bartender who extends an invitation for
a family dinner The Stranger is
initially hesitant but he eventually
agrees to do it afterwards he joins the
hotel manager's family for the dinner
event there he notices that the maid
isn't allowed to join them despite being
a part of the family curious the
stranger inquires about the reason to
which the hotel manager asserts that
there must be someone to serve
throughout the dinner there are long
awkward pauses leaving the stranger with
no idea of the topics to talk about
after a while an argument initiates
between the manager and his son
regarding the rules and regulations of
Renata when the stranger cannot
withstand the awkwardness anymore he
gets up and leaves at midnight he hears
the crying voice of the maid as a result
he walks towards her and offers to help
but she runs away saying that no one
helps her moments later The Stranger
stumbles upon a control room housing an
array of CCTV monitors this shockingly
reveals that all the rooms are monitored
by hidden cameras with this newfound
information The Stranger rushes to his
room and checks every nook and corner to
locate the covert camera just then the
television suddenly turns on and
broadcasts footage of the maid's
involvement in delivering pills to the
businessman assisting the elderly lady
with her bath and engaging in intimate
moments with Ginny's boyfriend at this
point the stranger senses something
amiss about the entire Hotel driven by
his suspicions he exits the room and
stealthily investigates an unused Hotel
chamber at the same time the bartender
spots him and provides him with a key to
access the same chamber upon entry he
discovers several pieces of laboratory
equipment including different acids
syringes vessels with blood dripping
from them and also some notebooks regard
starting pregnancy and genetic
alteration after witnessing all of this
the stranger's suspicions intensify as
he senses that the employees as well as
the guests of the hotel are together
experimenting something illegal and
unethical following this The Stranger
rushes into Ginny's room only to
discover her boyfriend administering an
unfamiliar substance into her body The
Stranger confronts her boyfriend but
soon after the hotel manager enters
grabs him and locks him within his room
in the next scene the bartender goes to
the maid and forces her to seduce The
Stranger At first she hesitates but
reluctantly agrees when he threatens to
burn down her cherished doll the
innocent maid then proceeds to the
stranger's room and begins to undress in
front of him however the stranger seems
to know that she is being forced hence
he decides to flee the hotel with her on
the other side the bartender who is
observing their actions from the control
room alerts the other guards and directs
them to stop the fleeing Duo as soon as
they hear the announcement the guests
immediately begin to pursue the stranger
in the maid their reaction indicates as
if they are being controlled by the
hotel manager's computer system the
manager tries to stop his son from
jeopardizing the entire Hotel system but
the bartender overrides the system
locking his father inside the control
room the old man tries to break free but
he accidentally strikes his head hard in
this process which results in his death
meanwhile The Stranger in the maid
nearly approached the exit door when the
stranger feels a sudden pain in his
heart causing him to collapse to the
ground he tries his best to rise and
flee but right then the bartender
arrives there and knocks him out the
rest of the guests then capture the maid
and act as controlled zombies to
forcibly undress her after this the
bartender unbuckles his belt and asserts
himself on the innocent maid what the f
in the final scene The Stranger regains
Consciousness to witness the Grim's side
of the maid's lifeless body on the floor
breaking him into tears he crawls
towards her drags her towards the exit
door where the paralyzed woman is also
lying down dead in a crying voice he
pays tribute to the maid's Soul by
singing the same song she had once
performed this script was pulled
straight from the dream journal of a
psychopath subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching